Dr Bryant Dr Clough and Dr gears all sat
around a conference table the monitor
beside them giving a direct encrypted
video link to 05-1 the most senior
member of the legendary 05 Council only
one topic was on the roster today the
inherent nature of one of the most
problematic anomalies
scp-682 the hard to destroy reptile
there were certain facts that were easy
to ascertain about 682 like the fact
that its default State appears to be
vaguely reptilian the fact that it's
highly aggressive and the fact that it
is seemingly impossible to kill the rest
it seems is still largely shrouded in
mystery how can we expect to terminate
this creature if we don't fully resolve
to understand it Dr gears offered it
appears that all of our efforts so far
have amounted to firing a gun in the
dark and hoping for the best do you have
any idea how much money we've blown on
the termination effort so far but
believe me the numbers would shock you
Dr bright chimed in with as the only one
in this room who's literally been inside
this Monster's head referring to the
incident where 682 was made to ingest Dr
Bright's Medallion in hopes of letting
the doctor's Consciousness take over the
Beast which didn't work I think I speak
to a degree of authority when I say I'm
not sure if we'd have any luck actually
understanding it it's like asking a
volcano how it feels about erupting Dr
clef thoughts on the matter were
predictable okay look I may not have
mine melded with this Abomination like
Jack but I've got two working eyes and a
decent brain attached to them that's all
I need to tell you our solution here is
obvious more Firepower we've been going
easy on this thing so far letting it
face different anomalies one at a time
not going at it with any truly heavy
weaponry and for some stupid reason
ruling out nuclear armaments that had
everyone around the room rolling their
eyes there he goes with nukes again Dr
bright said nukes nukes nukes if you
love nukes some much why don't you marry
them huh clef clef grumbled in
frustration why did everyone around here
get so risk adverse feinhardt never won
fair minor killed giant ugly lizards why
should we treat a nuke like it's such a
dirty word Dr Gear's side if the break
room coffee machine malfunction you'd
tell us to make sure the nuclear
response option stays on the table Cliff
cluff banged his hand on the table
because I believe in getting results no
matter what enough o5-1 barked silencing
the room everyone turned to the Monitor
and gave their undivided attention as
their Superior spoke I can staunchly
confirm that we will not be pursuing a
nuclear option for 682 under any
circumstances I do not intend on
creating a Godzilla we need to fight
gears I think you're on to something
we've done all we can to analyze scp-682
Through The Eyes of scientific
empiricist perhaps we need to look at it
Through The Eyes of its fellow anomalies
the ones that arm's completely insane
anyway make it happen gentlemen chop
chop and so they did all three of the
incredibly different doctors did see the
wisdom in o5-1's new Theory perhaps they
could gain a holistic understanding of
682 by collating knowledge gained from
other anomalies and through this
knowledge they might also be able to
find a weakness that somehow slipped by
unnoticed right now 682 was like an
impenetrable locked door but even the
most durable locked door can be defeated
with the right key there were certain
anomalous perspectives on scp-682 that
they already had take for example that
of scp-343 the kind reality warper also
known as God when confronted with
scp-682 during a termination attempt the
two of them seemed patently unaware of
each other's presence when quizzed on
the subject 343 claimed that 682 wasn't
one of his perhaps implying some kind of
extra dimensional origin it also lends
Credence to the popular theory that 682
was one of the children of the Scarlet
King though for now that would still
remain nothing more than a theory not
something they could really act upon
this was why each of the three
researchers following the orders from
05-1 began canvassing reactions from
other intelligent anomalies in hopes of
getting a useful kernel of information
from a fresh new angle Dr bright who has
frankly seen far too many movies thought
of himself as Clary Starling
interviewing a whole collection of
Hannibal lecters in hopes of gaining a
unique Insight that would help him catch
the killer when he shared this thought
with Dr clef and Dr gears gears told
bright that he didn't watch movies and
cleft called bright a nerd after the
proper safety precautions were put in to
make sure that the two never actually
came into physical or mental contact Dr
clef had scp-035 the devious diabolical
possessive mask attached to a Anakin
host body and brought in to observe as
cp682 in a sealed chamber clef asked the
possessive mask to relay any thoughts he
had while looking at the Beast
admittedly Dr clef felt a little
unnerved by how gleeful The Mask looked
while watching the hard to destroy
reptile clambering around in its tank oh
yes yes the possessive mask said it's
words like cyanide in the ears what a
truly marvelous creature so large so
powerful so violent oh I can feel the
hatred radiating off of it from here you
know the hateful ones are often the
easiest to manipulate there's so much
they'll do for power so much they'll
sign away while the malice aligns them
oh delightful such a wonderful thought I
don't suppose you'd let him wear me
would you Dr Cliff shook his head not on
your life creep sadly it didn't seem as
though any new insights had really been
gained here hopefully Dr gears would
have a little more luck with his project
Dr gears had decided to take a more
measured approach unsurprising given
this is Dr gears were talking about and
went for an intelligent anomaly who
probably wasn't harboring some evil
ulterior motive
scp-507 The Reluctant Dimension Hopper
two things highly benefited Dr gears in
this regard firstly The Reluctant
Dimension Hopper had gotten around and
seen more things than pretty much any
other Mortal being in existence secondly
as C p507 had certain aspirations namely
to become an SCP Foundation researcher
where he could be accepted and make a
profession out of his interest in the
Supernatural gears could leverage this
to gain cooperation when scp-507 was
brought in to observe 682 gears noticed
a certain flicker of recognition in the
dimension Hopper's eyes before the man
opened his mouth and said oh God not
another one of those things gears
immediately fired back another one you
said
scp-507 nodded ah during one of my jumps
I was in this big weird landscape
covered in freaky looking rocks there
were a whole bunch of these guys there
like a herd or a pack or something as
soon as they saw me they started chasing
me it was honestly pretty tense for a
second there I don't even know if I'd
make it out alive Dr gears nodded and
continued taking notes do you have any
further observations from your time
seeing these creatures in another
dimension
scp-507 shook his head presumably
disappointed that he couldn't offer more
thank you that'll be all then 507 Dr
gears said and of course that left one
more the Maverick the Joker in the pack
Dr Jack Bright the man from whom you can
only ever really expect the unexpected
he decided to take the middle ground
between the offerings of Dr gears and Dr
clef
scp-049 the plague doctor the mysterious
being who can kill with a touch but has
aspirations to heal Dr Bryant was
extremely interested in seeing what he
had to say about the nasty reptile that
same day the plague doctor was feeling a
little irritated to say the least he'd
been conducting some extremely important
Research into the pestilence on a cow
carcass when suddenly in order from the
top deemed he would no longer have
access to animal subjects lavender had
been pumped into his cell to pacify him
while five heavily armored guards
entered and dragged out his latest
subjects it was cruel it was inhumane it
was anti-science first they'd taken away
his live Human subjects then they'd
taken away his dead human subjects
followed by his live animal subjects if
he wasn't even allowed to perform his
vital research on animal carcasses now
then what hopes did he have of making
progress well out there in the world
every single day the pestilence spreads
further who even knows what form it has
taken now after all diseases shift and
mutate with the times and the whole
world was a petri dish out there as the
plague doctor was lost in this musings
Dr bright approached and wrapped his
knuckles on the Plexiglas of his
containment chamber leave me be doctor
the plague doctor side having dueling
your compatriots already taken enough
from me I'm not here to take doctor I'm
here to give Dr bright said I know we
can be a little harsh in our measures
sometimes doc but we're cold not cruel
you play ball with us you'll find we can
be very amicable to the tune of say
getting your live animal research
privileges back there was a moment of
silence before the plague doctor rose up
and walked out over to the divider
between himself and Dr bright he cocked
his head slightly as though taking in Dr
Bright's measure what would you have me
do in return doctor the plague doctor
asked Dr bright smiled there's just
something I want you to look at with the
assistance of a few security officers
the plague doctor was moved over to an
observation chamber joining on to a
larger more secure chamber the plague
doctor sat on a plush chair staring
through a one-way mirror into the larger
chamber Dr bright turned on a Dictaphone
hoping to record any interesting
observations the plague doctor came out
with what great pal am I supposed to be
looking at Dr Brian he asked oh they're
bringing him in now won't be a moment Dr
bright said a large door in the larger
chamber opened and several members of
personnel dragged in a tied up
incapacitated
scp-682 looking like it was still
recovering from heavy injuries
immediately scp-049 scene to tense up Dr
bright was fascinated watching the
plague doctors previously calm demeanors
suddenly become marked by clearly
evident worry what was he thinking would
it be a useful Insight the silence
continued as the plague doctor seemed to
carefully observe the immobilized Beast
for a moment or two Dr bright even
noticed the plague doctor's hands
shaking slightly moments later the
doctor cleared his throat and said the
pestilence never have I seen it so
malignant come again doc Dr bright asked
this thing it is sick dreadfully sick it
is a Bastion of disease a herbinger of
plague unlike anything I've ever seen
before how long have you had this filthy
thing within your walls doctor how many
people have made contact with it quickly
please I must know for the safety of all
of you as the plague doctor became
increasingly agitated Dr bright became a
mix of deeply concerned and Incredibly
curious sure scp-049 tended to go off
about a lot of things allegedly being
infected with the pestilence but this is
different there is genuine fear shaking
in the plague doctor's voice I I feel
unwelcome the plague doctor said rising
shakily to his feet please escort me
back to my Chambers I simply cannot deal
with such a case without proper
preparations he would be too dangerous
Dr Wright ordered the security Personnel
to make the plague doctor's desire a
reality he would be escorted back to his
chamber be given a lavender supplement
as well as a meal of beef and hard
cheese his favorite to help him
recuperate from his shock but all
throughout this process Dr bright had
latched on to one fragment of the
doctor's mutterings I simply cannot deal
with such a case without proper
preparations did that mean with the
proper preparations as cp049 could deal
with scp-682 and as with most of 049's
patience did deal mean kill if so then
this project was really about to Bear
some impressive fruit after giving the
plague doctor a few days to get himself
reoriented Dr right returned with
another offer one he wasn't even sure he
had the authorization to make but if his
plan worked out he was sure he could
swing it he offered the plague doctor
the chance to work with human subjects
again if he could first successfully
treat
scp-682
it would certainly be an undertaking
scp-049 said trying to hide his clear
discomfort but for the sake of science I
must accept over the next few days the
preparations were drafted up and the
plague doctor was given any equipment or
resources he requested for the task of
curing
scp-682 then when the day came
scp-682 was tied up and sedated once
again and dragged into a large
cross-testing chamber where Dr Wright
the plague doctor and several members of
security Personnel were waiting it was
now or never would the doctor be able to
do it for what it's worth I Believe In
You doc Dr bright said giving a
tentative thumbs up the plague doctor
didn't return the thumbs up he was too
busy trying to stop himself from visibly
shaking in the face of this giant
diseased monstrosity would he have any
hope of treating such a beast he exhaled
and approached as with all of his
patients his first step would be to lay
a hand on the monster which normally
rendered it peaceful and still the
plague doctor slowly walked over his
hand extended feeling the prickles of
fear all over his body he could do this
he could do this but as he approached
scp-682 had somehow freed one of its
arms and swung for scp-049 with its
vicious claws 049 screamed and stumbled
back hitting the ground and crawling
away in the opposite direction
practically wheezing with Terror he
eventually gathered himself up in the
corner and curled into a ball shaking Dr
bright breathed a sigh of disappointment
it seemed this entire Venture had been
Awash take 049 back to his cell Dr
bright said resigned we're all done here
for everyone else it was just another
failed cross test quickly forgotten with
all the others for scp-049 was one of
the most traumatic experiences of his
life one that would stay with him
forever and be the reason he would
always be afraid of
scp-682 want an anomaly of your own
check out scpswag.com for high quality
SCP merch now go check out could scp-682
be contained in the back rooms and what
did scp-049 do during the actual black
plague for more stories of the plague
doctor and this nasty nasty reptile